special thanks to squarespace for
sponsoring this video stick around for
later to hear more about squarespace now
i know everyone has their favorite
spidey cartoon and the usual picks are
one of these three depending on when you
were born for three different
generations these are the definitive
adaptations of spidey in animation
but there's a middle chapter in here
from the early 2000s that is often
looked past
one is a series that seemed like a
strange and unique idea that no one
really gravitated towards another that
was ambitious and mature but didn't
quite catch on
these are the two unloved middle
children of spider-man cartoons the ones
that only lasted 13 episodes each the
ones that don't get much fan art or
belated action figures or a video essay
about why they're so awesome but i'm in
four videos deep so i'll be the one to
cover them i guess
i told you part three wouldn't take
seven months it only took 15
which tells you my level of interest in
making spider-man content at this point
haha not a spider-man channel so funny i
love that joke
don't don't put that in don't put that
in ben don't put that a ben
justice league unlimited this show is
bizarre it's not based on any comic
story lines in particular
features dozens of original characters
it doesn't even take place on earth
and it's not a sequel to the previous
cartoon
they try to trick you and make you think
it might be a continuation with this
little musical cue
what could possibly be
but they didn't get permission to use
that [ __ ] spider-man unlimited was one
of those shows made to fulfill a
contractual obligation not because
anyone was really eager to make it which
as we know leads to some of the best
superhero stuff marvel entertainment and
fox kids had a deal to put out another
spider-man show in 1999 to reinvigorate
the spidey brand after the 90s show was
cancelled
originally it was supposed to be some
kind of super low budget motion comic
style adaptation of the first 26 issues
of the books but then sony and marvel
made a deal to do the movie
we all remember the movie
this one actually came out and part of
that deal was a side cartoon series that
would use the comics as source material
this conflicted with spider-man
unlimited's production and when the dust
settled they were told that they weren't
allowed to use any of spider-man's
supporting cast his classic costume or
adapt any comic stories from the classic
books
so the producers are like well [ __ ] what
do we do now
oh wait spiderman 2099 is a thing
because it's the 90s
so for about a week they were working on
that but then decided it was just a
little too similar to batman beyond
which was already in itself very heavily
influenced by both versions of
spider-man for its main character being
a high school superhero and its setting
being in a cyberpunk future it's a
rip-off of a rip-off of a spin-off
for a while they were settled on having
spidey go to another version of earth
where his uncle ben hadn't died and he
didn't have the mental fortitude to
fight off the symbiote and became the
venom of that world
then one of the producers was like no
clone saga will live in infamy and this
is the 90s so that's a really fresh
wound so don't do two peter parkers and
as such we finally got this end result
[Music]
this is a weird frankenstein's monster
of all these rules stipulations and
sources of inspiration it's kind of
batman beyond because look he's got his
fancy suit he could turn invisible it's
kind of spider-man 2099
jumping on cars he's got the cape it's
kind of classic spider-man and uh it's i
guess it's like kind of thundercats too
somehow
and it's um
it's not bad
well okay it is but i also kind of like
it the plot of this one which i'll admit
is a bit of a nightmare train wreck is
that scientists have discovered there's
an identical planet to earth on the
opposite side of the sun from us that's
got its own advanced society and
civilization just doing their own thing
how no one on either planet managed to
notice this before 1999 is beyond me so
they send astronaut john jameson there
to go make first contact with the local
populace except for reasons not
explained until later venom and carnage
are compelled to hijack the shuttle and
go to counter earth 2 for some nefarious
plan
as a kid i was instantly annoyed that
carnage and venom were teaming up and
referring to themselves in the singular
and also like
morphing around like clay face
a symbiote is gooey yes but you can't
walk through a chain-link fence with one
there's still a human being with bones
inside there man
even the show calls this out as being
weird and wrong but they don't explain
how or why suddenly they can do this
stuff hey you two could never morph like
that before
i just may be out gunned here or why
these sworn enemies that hate each other
in a dozen other comics and adaptations
just like
just calling each other brother and are
like total besties now
what have you done
the first episode is my favorite of the
whole show because the one that feels
the most like an actual spider-man
cartoon instead of
all this other weird stuff
peter parker fails to stop venom and
carnage from boarding john's shuttle and
he has to fortnite his way back to the
familiar planet earth of people who
think he's a colossal dumbass that can't
do nothing right he's a social pariah
and gets his ass kicked constantly until
he's just wondering if he should hang it
up for good but he sees a transmission
from john jameson saying everything on
counter earth has gone real
counterproductive and he needs some help
so sportily mangs steal some unstable
molecules from the fantastic four makes
himself a video game unlockable costume
that's stylistically designed to be
impossible to cosplay
and makes off with his own shuttle to
opposite land
listen up world this is spider-man on my
way to counter earth to save john
jameson and clear my good name
and i'm going with him peter parker
after all what newspaper man could turn
down an opportunity like this you could
tell his show was written really fast
without a great long term plan because
that makes no goddamn sense let's say
everything goes great and he gets jon
home really fast how's he going to
explain why only peter parker or
spider-man are going to step off the
spaceship and not both
oh yeah spider-man um heroically died on
counter earth or something just me now
that could be how he quits in the show
cause spider-man are always quitting on
me in this time period were they going
to have him explain to john the double
identity thing and they'd have to come
up with a plan together maybe just land
the shuttle far away from people and
then say spider-man got out and ran off
on his own and it's just peter and john
there i don't
i don't know
either way he set himself up for failure
because three people need to walk out of
this thing at the end of the journey
think before you speak dude
and we get to the main setting in the
series where it gets a lot less
interesting um
counter-earth is a land where a
scientist who now calls himself the high
evolutionary has learned how to
accelerate evolution in animals to make
them bipedal and intelligent like humans
and then he decides that those are way
cooler than humans and asserts that as
the new dominant species in society
under his rule while normal humans are
considered the lower class minority
because they're not big cool rhino dudes
or tiger guys
yeah yeah get your jokes out now
spider-man escaped from the planet of
the furries you'd think the mutant
animal people would be considered the
freaks and treated as the oppressed
class on this planet but somehow it's
flipped and also this planet has flying
cars and way more advanced technology
spidey discovers john jameson has joined
the underground human resistance
fighting for equality with
with the beastials
yes that's they're called the b steels
these things
we couldn't have found a better name
it really had to be that
how did not one person on the production
think that was strange were they
laughing and thinking the kids wouldn't
get it so they could just get away with
it it's all a big joke anyway peter
lives in a slum in counter-earth's new
york with some doctor that's a landlord
and her son and sells pictures of
spider-man to another newspaper on this
planet because sometimes you just gotta
stick with what you know also he teams
up with the resistance and battles a
rotating cast of counter-earth variants
of established spider-man villains like
electro but he's an electric eel yeah
that'll do it or craven but he's
actually pretty much just
exactly the same as normal crave and he
said he just has a different haircut i
guess
i can't believe rhino and scorpion
weren't here that seems really obvious
maybe maybe they weren't allowed to use
them
this was so crazy i blame this show for
all the damn nano machine suits in the
movies
how do his shoes fit inside the [ __ ]
how does it do that in both things i'm
confused
though i do wish this costume would
appear in something other than the games
and that weird comic where carnage was
placed by another carnage from an
alternate universe so it got really
weird convoluted yeah a version of this
world got killed off by moreland and
spider-verse but they said it's an
offshoot not the canon ending to this
show or spider-man and his amazing
friends don't you even bring up that
dumb [ __ ] in the comments you goober
see another one of these guys is over
here in spider-geddon a few years later
he's fine there's like an infinite
number of spider-man unlimited universes
cause that's i mean that's how that
works
i will praise this series for a few
things the art style is incredible
i love the heavy inking and the vibrant
colors on the backgrounds these
character designs are really complex and
detailed and i can't believe they made
those poor animators draw these frame by
frame
i wish we could have another animated
series that looked this good because
this style is great this is the best
looking of all the 90s marvel cartoons
in my opinion and of course the voice
acting is pretty good reno romano was
chosen to play spidey and he did such a
great job they brought him on board to
voice the two video games from around
this time a spider-man made off with
octavius's new invention but not the
spider-man not me somebody's framed me
why i don't know yet and if new york's
finest catch me it may be too late even
though those were kind of off shoots of
the 90s show i wish he'd voice this
character again in something because i'm
really nostalgic for his performance
from these games plus he's got enough
range that he also voices counter
earth's version of green goblin who's
actually an anti-hero and member of the
human
one
resistance
it's dangerous but the fate of the world
depends on it i will do what no other
superhero on the planet would even
consider
in here also my pal gary chalk is here
is counter earth's new york newspaper
editor-in-chief subscribe to xavier for
more videos like this one
once again this series is not in
continuity with the 1994 show even
within this show they have flashbacks to
this spidey's version the symbiote saga
and it's similar
but still out of sync ending with venom
being brought in by shield instead of
the police and him choosing to make
carnage as a partner to help him fight
spider-man instead of all that nonsense
with baron mordo and dormammu and what
the [ __ ] plus cletus and eddie swapped
hair colors for some reason you really
only need to watch a handful of episodes
of the show to get the gist and then
there's a lot of filler in the middle
that's not particularly good
sorry i just don't care much for the
tragic backstory of
get the mute guy that is made of
sentient bandages and wear sandals all
the stuff focused on venom and carnage
is way off from the comics but
are some of the stronger episodes in
this show weirdly enough eddie brock's
character is still pretty well preserved
in this he's just under some kind of
mind control from venom being connected
to a hive mind of green prehistoric
symbiotes that live on counter earth and
have over time evolved into insects or
something i could barely follow the show
but i don't dislike it you could put it
on and zone out while running on the
treadmill because comic-con is right
around the corner and you gained a lot
of depression weight during the last two
years but hey you're finally married and
things are a little better so it's time
to start taking care of yourself again
so you can feel confident wearing
spandex in a public space
projecting slightly
but alas pokemon was a runaway success
in most animated tv networks at the time
wanted to chase that money train so
marvel stuff was left in the dust for a
bit and this show was shut down before
staff writer larry brody could script
where to go from here
this series
feels like it was destined to end
abruptly there's no way this could have
carried on for any more than like two
seasons maximum before it got tedious
and even weirder even if they did
outline plans for 11 more episodes after
this at some point you just have to let
spidey go home
it ends on a monster of a cliffhanger
where everything goes wrong all at once
the villains get away and spidey and
friends are buried under a collapsing
building while an army of symbiotes
invades the whole city like those three
video games where that happened
how season two could tie this in a neat
and tidy bow i have no idea but i'll
give it my best shot hey self plug go
read my fan comic i can't make money off
of it but i like when people tell me i
did a good job and pat me on the head
and say they're proud of me because my
mom never did because she's just like oh
you listen to your wife when she tells
you to do the dishes but not me i see
how it is xavier
anyway spiderman unlimited
this time he's gone too far
the all-new all-improved spider-man
davison's rescue is my responsibility to
be the only one who can bring him home
after all the times i've risked my life
with this stinking city this is the
thanks i get some
change no matter where i go in the
universe everybody hates spiderman
please
help
but that's one request i can't turn down
how long have you been following me long
enough to know your deepest darkest
secrets
[Music]
someday somehow
[Music]
not great or terrible
certainly could have been a lot worse
but it's such a strange and off-the-wall
show and there's no way they'd make
something this dramatically far off from
your traditional spidey ever again i
find it special just because of how
unique it is and the fact that it
happened at just the right time before a
show like this could never be made again
because the movie came out shortly after
and skyrocketed spidey's popularity to
new heights now everyone had a pretty
standardized idea of what spider-man
stuff should look like and all the shows
hereafter would follow suit the closest
to the cinematic spidey being this
handsome low polygon gentleman that has
the same haircut but was allowed to cuss
and go to parties with beer spider-man
had a rough transition to 3d
from the fellas at mainframe
entertainment who brought you uncanny
valley nightmare fuel and the most
underrated transformers cartoon
comes spidey's first foray into a fully
3d animated setting
boy we've come a long way to
spider-verse this series was produced by
brian michael bendis and originally
started out as an adaptation of his and
mark bagley's ultimate spider-man books
early into the show's life bendis
himself penned a pilot for the show and
it was eventually picked up by mtv
which is a weird choice but i i guess i
can't see this really running on fox
kids as it is you can see a lot of
ultimate spider-man influence on the
visual presentation of this show a few
years later when the angsty little
rascal himself had his debut in a 3d
video game he and his world ended up
looking very similar to this take cell
shaded 3d was new at the time and was
very popular style for comic book
adaptations
i wish more stuff looked like this these
days the look of this show is really
special and while not aging as
gracefully as the aforementioned video
game it's still really impressive for
the time and as much as i love beast
wars
this show looks a hell of a lot better
than the studio's previous work this
time around mainframe studios were given
the task of creating a new spider-man
show to coincide with the success of sam
raimi's mega blockbuster event of 2002
with a director who previously worked on
cg television shows backed by a studio
who pioneered the first fully cgi
cartoon reboot
ado payton was very eager to give
spider-man a fresh spin with a stylish
coat of paint the team set out to do
something that had never been done
before they wanted to bring the colorful
and dynamic lighting of a comic book to
life in a way that couldn't be done with
traditional 2d animation on a tv budget
alongside the obvious ultimate bagley
influence on the youthful look of our
characters adu also cited ramita and
todd mcfarlane's artistic styles as
having influenced the show we've been
looking at comic books john romita
junior's work john romita senior
mcfarland a number of great artists have
supported the spider-man stories over
the years and
for us one of the first steps was just
to put all that stuff in front of us you
can even see the mcfarland dubbed
spaghetti webbing he popularized during
his tenure at marvel made its way into
the show plus this is the only cartoon
spidey that frequently does these
back-breaking todd mcfarland poses with
ease hot damn that is a flexible man i
hear a lot of people say this show is
unwatchable and the animation is ugly
and it looks bad and blah blah blah
and you guys are spoiled by your damn
nickelodeon ninja turtles and your clone
wars and your small titty goth gf show
all this movie quality animation on
television now i can tell none of you
[ __ ] had to contend with max steele
no the old max steel
it's not that far off from these other
shows from around the same time but the
cel-shaded filter goes a long way to
hiding the seams i think
plus the actual animation which is
different from art style
is buttery smooth this spidey moves like
water he's so
fast
and these moves are badass
i love the fight choreography in this
series we still haven't gotten a
spider-man that can zip around like this
in more recent shows and i think that
shows the strength of the 3d keyframed
fight scenes
all of the peter parker daily life stuff
is motion captured to feel more casual
and believable but spider-man's
movements are hand animated to make him
feel more super
and it really sets the two halves of the
show apart i think the art style also
allowed for some really cool shots of
spidey at night with full black shadows
and rim lighting that look really
dramatic you can get some cool
wallpapers from this [ __ ] at least give
them a break kids they tried their best
they forgot to put the cel-shaded filter
on that lab coat in the background so
that has smooth shading so
so this sucks actually zero out of time
this show once again follows college
freshman peter parker who seemingly has
gone through the events of the previous
year's theatrical mega hit there's quite
a few cartoons that start like this
where the live action movie is implied
to be the backstory behind the show but
it obviously branches from the story of
the movie if it's set between sequels
like the last show there's enough here
to place this squarely in its own
universe such as mj harry and flash
thompson going to esu alongside peter
and the osbournes aren't exactly
themselves but it's close enough to
imagine at the time that this was
continuing the story audiences were
eager to see more of before the sequel
came along and completely squashed this
poor cartoon's hopes and dreams of ever
being canon spidey's got organic webs
and shares the same emblems and shiny
webs on his costume
norman is dead and harry blames
spider-man for it harry i get that you
think spider-man killed your father on
account of he did
if only i could cause you the pain that
you've caused me
first we'll see who's behind the mask
you can look into your eyes as you die
spiderman
you can't be
peter is working freelance for jameson
and mary jane and spider-man mentioned
sharing arguably the most iconic movie
kiss
well sure there was that kiss but it's
not like we ever went out salsa dancing
or anything like that peter faces off
against a bunch of c-listers and
original characters throughout this
series likely due to restrictions from
sony as to not have two conflicting
versions of doc ock or black cat since
she was originally considered for the
sequel a whole lot of that going around
with these shows
just very specific circumstances that
result in something that's quite unlike
anything else before or after we see a
handful of familiar faces like silver
sable electro eventually craven and poor
old doc connors oof
this uh
this didn't have a happy end
but the greatest of them all michael
clark duncan's kingpin makes an
appearance making this spider-man also
dubiously cannon to the daredevil movie
at the time but
outside of them it's all new guys
created just for the show a couple of
them don't even get their names dropped
so you have no idea what to call them
talon is this universe's resident cat
burglar but most people would probably
forget about this newspaper prop and
just call her by her real name cheyenne
since talon has never actually spoken
out loud you could honestly just replace
her with black cat in your brain and
this episode still works exactly the
same
the leader of this terrorist group with
high-tech jackets and sci-fi guns called
pterodactyx doesn't even get a prop
calling attention to his name i had to
look at the concept art for the show to
find out what it was and i still can't
remember it trying to watch this show
nowadays is incredibly annoying because
not only is it almost never streaming on
anything but when it is or when you
purchase it it's always out of order
it's always listed in its air date which
is unfortunately all over the damn place
because it turns out creating the future
is really difficult with 2002 technology
episodes that canonically come first are
often held until later in the season
because they just flat out weren't
finished yet
whatever was ready was what came out
which means characters that haven't been
introduced yet will walk in a frame like
you've known them for a while or events
we'll be called back to that haven't
happened yet max dillon becomes electro
and then dies and then shows up in class
again to tell peter not to mess around
with one of the many thousands of goth
girls voiced by tara strong that made it
in here only the dvd release of the
entire season has the episodes right
here's the order for anyone interested
by the way other than its animation
style the thing that really sets this
series apart from every other spidey
cartoon is its maturity since it was
aired on mtv this was a tv 14 show that
can mention alcohol depict characters
drinking and smoking show firearms and
blood and death and they could even cuss
hello good guy saved your butt me on the
ground now
some of these episodes got pretty damn
dark
it's pretty much everything the 1994
series chose not to do all packaged
together
and i think it makes a strong case for
some of these more adult elements also
making for interesting and dramatic
storytelling for example this show's
take on bullying pulls no punches with
showing the origin of max dillon a shy
nerd looking to fit in with the cool
frat guys into the deadly and murderous
electro they torture this poor kid over
and over but he's so desperate for their
approval he puts up with it with this
weak fake smile
the bullies invite max to a frat party
which is just a trick for another brutal
hazing prank that leaves him feeling
humiliated and powerless until his
powers activate because he's secretly a
mutant from x-men i guess look it up and
the first thing he does is kill the guy
who picked on him all this time and
peter reaches out to him knowing what
it's like to be bullied and given the
powers to finally stand up for yourself
he pleads with max to settle down and
stop hurting people but he's just too
manic to listen to reason and seize
everyone as his enemy
in the early 2000s post columbine there
were a lot of animated shows doing
episodes like this but of all of them
i've seen this one just feels the most
brutally truthful to the reality of
things
it doesn't end with them making up and
being friends and going to school
together like normal it ends in a
graveyard
i just hope wherever max is
he's finally found some peace
it's a really powerful episode that
demonstrates the full gambit of what the
show was capable of doing that no series
before or since could but this series
also has light-hearted and fun elements
too
i really love the banter and chemistry
between peter mj and harry in the show
and no spidey cartoon outside of this
has really nailed that dynamic the same
way
how about if i come late he's not coming
i'm serious he is so not coming
yeah unless later means
never
hello i said i'm coming what am i
invisible this mj feels closer to the
comics version than kirsten dunst
because she's more the pursuer in the
relationship and wants to get to know
peter and get in his head
and he's the one who brushes her off and
puts up a wall i think harry thinks
maybe we have things to talk about
i uh
uh
these binocs are pretty uh
fly
it's kind of flipped from the movie
relationship where peter's chasing her
at exactly all the moments when it's
most inconvenient in her life and she's
like are you [ __ ] kidding me bro i'm
marrying the leader of the human
resistance against the beast heals i
can't do this wishy-washy [ __ ] right now
man
that poor sad werewolf man was abandoned
at the altar harry osborne is also a
funny ass character in this show
thank you
he's such a chillaxed dude bro and he
only gets intense when spider-man is
brought up like of all the harry osborns
and all the cartoons i think this one is
the most charismatic and the one that's
like i could actually see why peter
would be his friend because he's not
just an annoying sniveling dweeb
i've already got it all figured out
actress parties supermodel parties
actress and supermodel parties yeah i'm
sure mj can't wait for those oh good
then we're on the same wavelength peter
is voiced this time by neil patrick
harris and i think he gives a really
strong performance
welcome to spidey's cardio workout
he doesn't sound like tobey maguire
really he's just doing his own thing and
it works
he's got this really nerdy nervousness
as peter parker actually spider-man is a
man
sort of but his voice becomes very
commanding and strong is spidey and i've
even heard that they pitched it down a
little so his spider-man could sound
more intimidating i think that's a cool
idea i'm gonna rip you apart craven hey
you know what i'm feeling right now yeah
no but i'm going to a whorehouse and i'm
going to get my [ __ ] on if you two don't
want to get your sweat that's fine with
me i honestly really like this series
and their take on the spider-man mythos
something still comic book-y but also
very down-to-earth and close to reality
i think spider-man the new adventures of
batman or whatever deserves a little
more love if you can look past the
admittedly aged visuals you'll see that
the story is pretty solid but as with
all weird 13 episode long cartoon shows
that were cancelled abruptly cliffhanger
the new spider-man series of animated
episodes about spider-man ends with a
two-parter where these villains called
the gains twins use mind control powers
to turn spider-man into their personal
assassin to get revenge on craven the
hunter for a personal vendetta they have
against him spidey really lets loose
here and it gets pretty brutal in this
fight until he comes to his senses
when he goes after the twins for putting
a brain whammy on him and kidnapping
mary jane they trick him into injuring
his friend indie dimanji a journalist
that peter has a romance with throughout
the show she's put into a coma from him
not pulling his punches with her and he
feels like spider-man is just too
dangerous to leave unchained so he hangs
it up and by hanging it up i mean he
puts it in a suitcase and throws it in
the river this is one of the only
spider-man stories to my knowledge that
actually ends with him definitively
going nah this sucks and quitting
permanently obviously this was going to
be resolved in season 2 as their attempt
to adapt spider-man no more but it never
happened
imagine if spider-man 2 just ended right
here
it's such a bummer of an ending and this
series wasn't cancelled because it had
low ratings it was actually doing very
well
mtv just decided it didn't fit in with
the rest of their programming because
they were getting away from adult
animation more into reality shows and
irredeemable annoying garbage
24 7 shows about stars remodeling your
house it's the same reason the beavis
and butt head reboot got canned
no not the new reboot the other reboot
from 2011. they're really doing that
twice
same with futurama
man 90s kids just really can't let
anything go can they
would the world like come to an end if
spider-man took one lousy night off
okay you made your point ever wonder
what my life is like it's like this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
these two shows are very strange and
distinctive compared to everything else
we've gotten for spidey in the realm of
animated shows i commend both of them
for trying something really different
that gave them such strong defining
traits
and while neither of them are perfect
and can both have some real duds for
episodes they also have some strong ones
that are worth checking out if you're a
fan of the character they both
understood and utilized spider-man in
interesting ways and i think they
deserve some recognition for at least
attempting something cool even if these
attempts were formed by stringent
mandates and troubled productions maybe
think of these as like one show that was
a weird anthology that switched off
concepts each season so it's less
depressing that they both got tossed in
the trash so quickly before really
taking off and even though these were
both a little out there in their own
ways a more traditional spidey show was
still on the horizon
i'd be a down and out broken depressed
spidey too if not for sponsors like
squarespace
squarespace gives you a user-friendly
and beautiful platform to maintain and
run your very own website you can
connect with your site's users through
gated members only content as well as
sending email notifications leverage
audience insights all on one easy to use
platform you can create your own
community with comments sections with
threaded comments and likes these handy
blogging tools built in can help you
easily categorize and share posts on the
site you can get even more from
squarespace with third-party extensions
to manage inventory promote products
streamline bookkeeping or whatever else
your site needs to run like a well-oiled
machine and you can even display posts
from your social media on your site to
make sure your followers are connected
and can share them too go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com forward slash this
special code to save 10 off your first
purchase for a website or domain
[Music]
you